is that camera yeah that's incredible
yeah look at it is that better than your
phone yeah it's an incredible quality
yeah here with Joe Rogan at the
weigh-ins oh hi you get nervous before
these things no I get excited though
how do you uh prepare for all the names
you have to read off
uh get them written out banana
when you look at these guys you see
excitement you see fear what do you
usually see the fighters yeah when they
stay uh us you never see fear I mean you
saw fear like when Anderson Silva was in
Pro in his prime he saw some fear it was
like when the guys reach this like
Unstoppable level you see some fear but
you don't generally you just see anxiety
and tension and you know you see guys
getting fired up for a fight intensely
intensity for sure who's the most
intense guy you've seen at the weigh-ins
ever
Connor gets pretty [ __ ] intense but
so this could be
um
it all depends on whether or not they
have like real animosity towards each
other Nate Diaz is probably somebody
that gets pretty intense oh yeah he's
gonna get intense that's gonna be a good
one just I don't know how they're going
to separate him from Hamza and him from
everyone else because everything's gonna
get crazy today it could get crazy yeah
and what are you gonna do are you gonna
be all right I'm gonna get the [ __ ] out
of there if [ __ ] gets wild I'm not
getting into scrap you gotta watch me
look like a coward
also here with Shane Gillis you're going
to step up if she goes down I'll get in
there all right I might have to get in
and get knocked out by a 120 pounder
you ever lose your voice for these
things no no I yell all the time you
know because of uh doing comedy my voice
is pretty strong this is like such a
surreal moment in human history the the
for combat like more Innovation is
happening combat in the past 20 years
then yeah every question for history
however and you're at the center of it
yeah when you did that hit you at which
point does that hit you before big
fights before big fights it's always
like Goosebumps it starts wheeling up
yeah yeah like before uh Leon Edwards
and Kamara usmano was like here we go
you know you just like your whole body
just tingles like all your skin tingles
and then the shock might happen like you
did in that fight oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
just like when something crazy happens
your whole body just jolts it's so it's
so wild you know like you see people
standing up and screaming oh my God
behind you and then you become a meme
yeah I become I'm a meme often but uh
the last one when uh Leon Edwards
knocked out Camaro uh you see me and DC
freaking out behind us Tony
oh my God
that was amazing it was amazing all
right brother thank you for uh giving us
a behind my pleasure
[Music]
[Applause]
versus Kevin
holidays
[Applause]
official 178 8.5
[Applause]
Ferguson
[Applause]
and his opponent
named Diaz
[Applause]
you all for coming out we'll see you all
tomorrow night
how do you feel after that that was
exciting that's very intense it was uh
it's gonna be one of those cards where
it's like no one prepared for that
opponent so you have three fights that
have been completely reworked and so
these guys have to adjust and you know
there's very different opponents okay
well what happened was hamzajimaya
didn't make weight and he missed weight
by eight and a half pounds which is so
crazy that they wouldn't let them fight
each other so they had to move that so
now you have Li Jing Leon versus Daniel
Rodriguez Rodriguez was supposed to be
fighting Kevin Holland that's right and
then Hamza was supposed to be fighting
Nate Diaz this way by a ton but honestly
Tony Ferguson versus Nate Diaz is a much
better fight much more competitive fight
and Hamza versus Kevin Holland is a real
test for homs on him Kevin Holland is a
big guy he fought at 185 pounds before
he was very successful knocked people
out including Joaquin Buckley at 185. I
think that's a real chance
it's a it's chaos surprise it's a
totally different kind of fight he's a
chaos kind of guy though yeah I mean I
think it's an exciting fight I'm excited
well I don't like the facts the best way
that's a lot to miswave by so there's
like two things could happen he miswade
because he didn't prepare properly which
usually indicates either he was sick or
injured or he didn't want to make the
way you know maybe he was like so worked
up by all this Nate Dia stuff that he
didn't want to get in the sauna he
didn't want to cut the weight who knows
what's going on we don't know yeah we
really don't know you'd have to get
friends with him where he could confide
in you and you tell you the truth it was
amazing to see you do this in person and
amazing to see the fighters in person
man thank you tomorrow's going to be
even crazier
foreign
[Music]
so
like this shot right here this is a
perfect example this seems like an easy
shot but you know it's not an easy shot
it's getting to that ball
I'm down there yeah so that ball when
the ball's down there like that like
kind of in the middle but not in front
of that hole there's only two places to
be on that door you have to be on the
right side of the ball or the left side
of the ball now when you have something
like this that's right for the whole it
seems like well that's an easy shot but
you have to make sure that you have the
right speeds
here and then it's got to go like this
all the way down to here
oh so two walls has got a bounce on this
one that one and all right basically
three rails maybe three rails and that a
little like a tap on the other one
wow that's strong that's strong yeah
yeah so it looks like that's easy but
that's not easy at all that that's like
one of the harder shots to get yourself
well you're in a perfect position to
make the next block how'd you get into
opening Anthony I was in bands with my
brother and uh I would write song
parries about everything that was
happening in the news and the OJ thing
you might heard of that happened and I
wrote a song tired about it I hope he
played it on his show uh WBAB on Long
Island and people loved it so he goes
hey can you come in and do it live and
me and my brother are like yeah came in
did it live and I thought this was my
shot I just poured everything out I
started doing impressions I was
commenting on the news and Opie goes uh
dude that was really good why don't you
come in next week again and it just
snowballed from there we got an offer to
go to Boston and I never looked back I
threw my sheep at all worker tools out
on 95 on my way up to Boston
all about knowing like the cue ball
speed and knowing Powerball is gonna
come off the ball when it contacts it at
an angle and it's you get completely
obsessive because it's so hard to
predict and then the more you do it the
more you get like muscle memory and the
more you kind of understand where the
ball is going so you're not even
thinking too much using intuition
there's a lot of thinking
things that happen at the same time it's
super complicated
it's fascinating
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]